it is December 15 2022 and you're
watching the code report after what felt
like a lifetime of waiting spelled kit
officially hit version 1.0 yesterday
which is a full stack framework for the
world's most loved UI Library when I
tried spell for the first time over
three years ago it left me extremely
titillated it had an Innovative compiler
elegant reactivity and we just had so
much fun together
as the years went on I continued working
with react and angular but truth be told
I would often close my eyes and pretend
that they were actually spell I was web
developmentally frustrated but luckily
just in time for Christmas we've
achieved a glorious climax that makes it
possible to use felt in a
server-rendered application let's take a
look at some code and see if it lives up
to all of these innuendos spelled kit is
very similar to other JavaScript meta
Frameworks Like nextjs Remix and nuxt
like next js13 it uses file system
routing but made a somewhat
controversial decision of using reserved
names to represent different types of UI
like page layout loading and error in
addition any file that has significance
to the framework is prefixed with a plus
sign there's been a lot of discussion
around this approach and not everybody
likes it because you end up with tons of
files in the project with the exact same
name which can lead to migraines if you
expand all the directories in your
editor on the other hand though these
conventions keep your project clear and
consistent page.spelt contains a
component that will be server rendered
when you navigate to that route after
the initial page load it will hydrate
and then the client-side router takes
over from there this is what we call SSR
and I think it's the most sensible
default however in spelled kit you can
mix and match other rendering strategies
like you can pre-render static HTML for
Jam stack style websites or if no server
is required you can use client rendering
to do everything in the browser or on
the flip side if you don't want any
JavaScript at all you can render
everything on the server like a
traditional multi-page application
what's awesome though is that you can
choose the best rendering strategy for a
page with a simple configuration option
you're not locked into just one
rendering Paradigm that's awesome but
the other big thing you'll want to know
about the developer experience is how
data fetching works every page.svelt
file can have a matching page.js or TS
file that exports a load function the
return value from this function will
automatically be made available in the
page.spilt file via this data variable
it's incredibly simple and also provides
end-to-end type safety the load function
can run both server side and client-side
however if you want to limit it to just
the server you can do that by adding
server to the file name and speaking of
server I love spell Kit's convention for
building apis you create a server.js
file then export functions named as HTTP
verbs like get post patch and so on
that's nice but here's where things get
really cool in many applications you
need to fetch data at multiple levels
like you might have user data at the
root than a dashboard with an order then
some comments below it fetching all this
data is complex and people have come up
with all kinds of complex State
Management libraries that try to Wrangle
the complexity in spell kit you can do
nested routing with layouts that can
share UI with their children and also
fetch data that's accessible by the
children but what's special about svelte
is that it has built-in stores the page
store gives you access to all the data
on the current page and can be
subscribed to with reactive updates from
anywhere in the application by putting a
dollar sign in front of it angular has
actually been doing stuff like this for
years with its async pipe and I can tell
you from experience that patterns like
this eliminate tons of complexity when
it comes to State Management now it's
also important to know that when
fetching data you can have error and
loading files that represent the UI for
those special States this pattern is
basically identical to nextjs version
13. in addition spell kit has form
actions which allow you to Define
functions on the server that handle form
submissions at this point pretty much
every modern framework has stolen this
feature from remix which itself got the
idea from the way every other PHP
framework has worked since the beginning
of time and another piece of bonus news
is that spelled kit is also getting a
library very similar to next auth for
user authentication Rich Harris the
creator of spelled and spell kit works
at versel and the team from next auth
developed this Library which is awesome
because that means it's getting
world-class tools proven to work at the
largest scale overall spelled kit is a
genre defining Masterpiece if you want
to penetrate deeper into this topic stay
tuned for a full uncensored tutorial on
Beyond fireship this has been the code
report thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one